what's on your like kind of risk map in
terms of ways out for Putin is it Trump
being reelected
I can't see Trump being re-elected
because I think he's too mired and filth
the problem really DeSantis could make
it but this answers is good on Ukraine
I'm I'm I'm having less nightmares about
Trump
um which is sweet
um so
I think that
that the the the the serious danger is
that Western politicians are used to
trading and dealing and compromising and
that's kind of in their DNA
and with dealing with uh with Russian
fascism
um by the way Putin didn't used to be
quite as fascistic as he is now so he's
there's something uh there's something
around about the the start of covid
where he he goes into a darker place
so when I met him in 2014 he was subtle
and sensitive enough to say oh here's an
irritating prick from the BBC Panorama
show you know what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna I'm gonna
treat him as if I'm a Democratic
president which he was very good at it
sounds like he was very
you know
well done president like he gave a long
and boring and fundamentally absolutely
dishonest answer but he gave me an
answer so I couldn't say he didn't
answer me
um and that guy
who has so he's become more
nationalistic it may be because he
thinks he's dying in which case and by
the way he may be wrong about thinking
he is dying but if he thinks he's dying
then he's got to move quickly because
he's run out of Road
but but I I feel that
the
um
the best way of ending this is to give
the ukrainians a heavy metal so that
Putin's War has failed
and then the Russian people the
oligarchs
some of the secret policemen around him
think
this guy is useless let's get rid of him
and the moment that sets in then
um
then that's not good news when a Russian
leader loses a war
their longevity is limiting